السلام عليكم ورحمه الله مشاهدينا في كل
مكان اهلا بكم في هذه التغطيه العاجله
للاحداث في السودان حيث افاد مراسله
الجزيره باندلاح معارك عنيفه بالاسلحه
الثقيله بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريع في المنطقه الصناعيه وحيي الحله
الجديده والرميله في الخرطوم مراسلون اضاف
ايضا انفجارات قويه ومتتاليه سمعت جنوبيه
مدينه ام درمان وذلك بعد اقل من ساعه من
انتهاء هدنه وقعها الجيش السوداني وقواته
والدعم السريع في مدينه جده السعوديه في
مدينه الخرطوم بحري قلم رسلونا ان طائرات
الجيش هي السوداني قصفت مناطق لتمركز
القوات الدعم السريع وذلك تحديدا في شرق
النيل وفي جسر الحلفايه شماليه الخرطوم
بحري نتابع التفاصيل اولا باول وينضم الي
من الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره اسامه سيدي احمد
مرحبا اسامه كيف تسير هذه التطورات
الميدانيه في الخرطوم
التطورات بدات متسارعه للغايه يعني منذ
الصباح منذ انتهاء الهدنه هدنه اليوم
الواحد التي توافق عليها كل من الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وفق ما طلبت
وساطه جده في كل من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه لم يعني تنتهي
تتجاوز الساعه بعد انتهاء هذه المهله عند
الساعه السادسه صباح اليوم بتوقيت الخرطوم
الا وقد اندلعت يعني
المعارك بضراوه في محاور شتى في العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري
وام درمان الان في هذه اللحظات تشهد يعني
معارك طاحنه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
هذه الاحداث بدت بالفعل متسارعه خلال
ساعتين الماضيتين خاصه ان هذه اللح في هذه
اللحظات هناك تحليق مكثف للطيران الحربي
للجيش السوداني في سماء واسعه من العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم الطيران الحربي التابع
للجيش السوداني قام بقصف مواقع في منطقه
شرق النيل يعني في الغالب انها مواقع
يتمركز فيها تتمركز فيها قوات الدعم
السريعه طبعا هذه المنطقه كانت مسرحا
كبيرا
لمواجهات لقصف يعني هذه المنطقه تحديدا
المنطقه شرق النيل تعرضت لقصف مكثف خلال
الايام الماضيه وكانت مسرحا مستمرا
لعمليات القصف الجوي لطيران الحربي للجيش
السوداني وتكرر هذا القصف من جديد بعض
انقضاء الهدنه عند الساعه السادسه صباحا
اذا تستمر تستمر يستمر للاشتعال هذا
القتال المتعدده في العاصمه في كل من
الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري وام درمان كذلك في
منطقه جسر الحلفايه من الجانب الشرقي
للجسر ايضا شهد مواجهات عنيفه واشتباكات
ما بين الطرفين استخدمت في هذه الاشتباكات
شتى انواع الاسلحه الخفيفه والثقيله هذه
المنطقه وغيرها من المناطق في منطقه الوسط
الخرطوم او في منطقه
[موسيقى]
في المنطقه الصناعيه وسط الخرطوم وفي بعض
الاحياء المجاوره للمنطقه الصناعيه
الخرطوم كذلك شهدت الاشتباكات عنيفه في
احياء الجوز والرميله هذه الاحياء متاخمه
لمنطقه للمنطقه الصناعيه الوسط الخرطوم
كذلك هذه المواجهات مستمره حتى هذه اللحظه
ونستمع بشكل كثيف الاطلاق القذائف التي
تطلق من الاسلحه ثقيله ونستمع ايضا يعني
لاصوات الاشتباكات التي يتم استخدام
فيها جميع انواع الاسلحه سواء كانت خفيفه
او متوسطه او ثقيله اذا تستمر هذه
المواجهات بشكل كثير ولا تزال هذه
المواجهات مستمره وسط تحليق مستمر للطيران
الحربي السوداني في سماء واسعه من المدينه
ايضا جنوب الخرطوم ايضا شهد يعني قصف
مدفعي ثقيل في خلال الساعات القليله
الماضيه خاصه وان هذه المنطقه ايضا
الشهيده اشتباكات عنيفه اشتباكات وشهدت
كذلك
فيما يتعلق باستمرار القصف وهذه المنطقه
جنوب تحديدا ايضا كانت مسرحا كبيرا
للقصف المدفعي وكان هناك ضحايا من
المدنيين كذلك خلال الايام القليله
الماضيه طبعا ما نشاهده في هذه اللحظات من
الدخان المتصاعد هو تاثيرات ونعم
ربما هذه الاعمده التي تتصاعد وانت في صدر
الحديث عنها هل تتعلق باشتباكات اليوم
الحديثه ام لا نزلنا نتحدث عن الاعمده
التي كانت تتصاعد من خزان الوقود الذي
اشتعل قبل ايام
ما نشاهده الان في هذه اللحظات من تصاعد
الاعمده الدخانيه بشكل كثيف ليس لديه
علاقه بالاشتباكات والمواجهات المستمره
خلال ساعات الماضيه ما بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع وانما هي بقايا
الاشتعال الضخم للحريق في احد اكبر
المستودعات الرئيسيه لمخزون الغاز والوقود
في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم طبعا كانت هذه
المنطقه قد شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه ايضا خلال
خلال اربعه ايام ماضيه وكاله مسرحا عنيفا
لمواجهات مستمره في هذه المنطقه اذا هذا
الدخان المتصاعد ليس له علاقه بهذه
الاشتباكات وانما تاثيرات الاشتباكات
السابقه وما تبقى من اشتعال النيران
بكثافه هذه المنطقه في واحد كما ذكرت لك
من اكبر المستودعات الرئيسيه لمخزون الغاز
والوقود في منطقه المستودعات جنوب الخرطوم
ولكن طبعا هذه
الدخان هذا الدخان طبعا مشتعل منذ نحو
خمسه ايام وطبعا له تاثيرات بيئيه كبيره
على كل سكان المجاورين له وله تاثيراته
طبعا فيما يتعلق بالسكان الذين يقطنون هذه
المناطق اسامه يرجى كذلك تنويه الى ان هذه
الاشتباكات التي توصف على نطاق واسع بانها
عنيفه تاتي فعليا بعد نهايه اقصر هدنه
ولكن انجح هدنه بحسب اعين كل المراقبين لم
تخترق تماما خلال 24 ساعه كامله
بالفعل طبعا هذه اهونه اليوم الواحد كانت
مغايره تماما عن بقيه الهدى التي تم
التوافق عليها ما بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريعه في بحسب اتفاق جده
كان قد اقر عددا من الهدن استمرت لايام
ولكن هذه الهدن فشلت فشلت فشلا كبيرا ولم
يتم الالتزام على الارض فعليا بهذه الهدن
اذ انها قد شهدت خروقات متعدده وشهدت
اشتباكات وقصف واشتعل فيها الميدان ولم
يكن هناك من التزام فيما يتعلق بالجانبين
بمعطيات الميدان خلال كل ايام الهدنه ولكن
هدنه الامس التي
استمرت لاربع وعشرين ساعه فقط وانتهت عند
الساعه السادسه من صبيحه هذا اليوم بتوقيت
الخرطوم كانت فعلا من انجح الهدن